anita minutes aluratek rester avec nous
parce que ce pas là aussi comment faire
pour remercier pour ces trois ans et
parce qu'on a eu un des plus grands fous
rires de toutes les deux que tous ces
trois ans sur des beats était sur un
enfant de star drapeyroux nous a appris
que gilles et isabelle avait faute et
qu'il avait eu un enfant vous l'avoir
fait l'image voulez-vous l'art montrer
et là je suis carrément passer sous la
table pour regarder ça il avait l'aurait
fait une danse endiablée agile et
apparemment ils ont commis l'irréparable
on a retrouvé la photo de leur fille
yula la regarder
elle a pris de quel côté il est bizarre
c'est malin votez vraiment mais c'est
elle et pas du tout l est pas français
je suis 100 pour essayer de la faire
venir dont là j'avais je la connais pas